تجربه جدا ساكت مرهقه لانه همم
طموح اللي اتحط في تجربه في تجربه
الثمانيه من الورق الى مخططات الاخراج
والانتاج همم حاجه همم
سقفها عالي قوي عشان توصل للسقف العادي ده
في بلاد كتير هتسافر يعني هتسافر كذا بلد
همم
هتعمل شغل بدقه شديده المخرج احمد مدحت
عمل شغل همم دونتيل يعني همم وهائل جدا
ولكن اخذنا وقت همم المناسب ده كان وقت
طويل وكان همم الشغل بس عزائي فيه انه
وجالي في النص انزلاق غضروفي فده اخرني
واخر الشغل وبعدين رجعت تشتغل بنصف طاقه
علشان ظهري وبتاع كل الذكريات دي وسافرنا
في الثلج في فرنسا كانت الدنيا برد جدا
وطيارتي ما جاءتش من بلجيكا يعني عندي
ذكريات
جدا مش كلها في الايه بتصب عندنا نجاح
المسلسل في عمل انا باحترمه جدا وبحبه جدا
من اول لقاءنا مع همم
المستشار تركي ال شيخ او ابو ناصر كما يحب
ان يقول دي همم
مع الاستاذ احمد مدحت مع الاستاذ همم
المنتج همم
المسلسل مع الاستاذ همم قناه ام بي سي
طبعا في مصر اللي هتعرض المسلسل كل ده همم
يخليك عارف الخطوه خطوه هو شخص شخص بتعامل
في هذا العمل كان شيء محترم